When solving this problem, x equals positive 7. Now, that's great work if you
got this one correct. Now, there were two ways to do this problem, we could
write these two bases with a base of four or we could write these two bases
with a base of two. I'll show you both methods, but first let's do the one with
a base of four. I know 16 is the same thing as 4 squared. And I also know 64 is
the same thing as 4 cubed. So we write each of these bases with a base of 4,
raised to a certain power. These other exponents stay on the outside of the
parenthesis. Now, we have a power raised to another power. Which means we can
multiply these two powers together. The same is true on the right hand side. We
have 4 to the 3rd raised to x plus 3. So, I'll multiply this power by this
power here, and I'll multiply this power of 3 by the power x plus 3. Notice too
that I'm putting the power in parenthesis. It's because I need to distribute
this 2 to both of these terms. The same is true for the 3. We multiply the 3 by
x, and the 3 by 3. Distributing the 2 here and here, and distributing the 3
here and here, we get these powers. Now we have bases of 4, and we can set
these two exponents equal to one another. So, we'll have 4x plus 2, set equal
to 3x plus 9. Next, we'll subtract 3x from both sides of the equation to get 1x
plus 2 equals 9. Then, we'll subtract 2 from both sides of the equation to get
our answer of X equal to 7. Now the other way to do this problem is to rewrite
the base of 16 and the base of 64 with powers of 2. 16 is equal to 2 to the 4th
and 64 is equal to 2 to the 6th. Next, we have powers raised to powers on both
sides of the equation. So we can multiply these two exponents together, here,
and we can multiply these two exponents together here. Now we have 2 raised to
the 8x plus 4, distributing this 4. And we have 2 raised to the 6x plus 18,
distributing this 6. Now that both bases are identical, we set these exponents
equal to one another. So we'll have 8x plus 4 equal to 6x plus 18. We'll
subtract 6x from both sides of the equation to get 2x plus 4 equals 18. Next,
we'll subtract 4 from both sides to isolate the 2x. So, 2x will equal 14.
Finally, we divide both sides by two to get 1x equals seven, our solution.